I like sense in some ways more than elocutionary force because sense lends itself to the more
singular, idiosyncratic, like, um, um, almost like the qualia of of the thing whereas elocutionary force
like I know I know that that's all part of elocutionary force but it's a little bit harder
for me to get there because elocutionary force just that that language tends to get me to focus
a little bit more on the effect and to think more like hey this doesn't represent or it doesn't mean
but it does some kind of work, you know, it does the action of, you know, of a kind of a verb in a sense
whereas sense there's obviously like it's an infinitive it's always, you know, too green, it's
always in the process of making the sense but that that word tends to for me to invoke the singularity
of um and the the becoming of of the sense to me yeah no I get that I mean I always have to start
with you know like you know I have to start with Austin's, you know, not all language is merely
representative it does things and then complicate the the relationship between those two things and
then finally on the back end get to the idiosyncrasy for me sense does that work right up front
I understand I mean I get that and you do have to do some work like I'm I'm just sort of saying
bracket per and locutionary force and think of illocutionary as primary which is already doing work
on Austin in order to say that but how about here's another word that I think to me is absolutely
equivalent with those is difference right like that to me is the same same I mean again it's not the same
concept it intervenes in a different milieu but it's a very like it's just easier for me to think
difference, iterability, you know, these those other sorts of terms are just sense I don't know why
but I just sense it's just so so big and vague to me you know I mean it's part of the reason that
he's working with it right but uh is it like a mist that arises between the corporeal linguistic
do you guys like the mist metaphor because that comes up in almost every uh series right it's like
a mist above the prairie I mean I feel like I don't know how comfortable it's evocative yeah it's
definitely I I like it but I can sense a certain amount of discomfort with with him with it where
he's he has to condition a whole lot and he's it's like he's like this is the best that I have but I
don't I'm not totally committed to it right I've had a rule for years which is if I pick up a novel
and the word mist is on the first page I put it down right away, um, you know, because it's trying to
create such an ambiance and it's and so I I don't have a particularly positive association with mist
but that's because I read a lot of sort of sci-fi kinds of things and there's a lot of mist
that isn't the most idiosyncratic rule for like I know it's not true for whether or not you're going
to read a book it's totally you you would be surprised by how many books have the word mist
like a fog or the equivalent of mist, yeah, on the first page because they're trying to set a kind
of ominous mysterious tone no pun intended, you know, I hate it I think the usage here right it's
supposed to be in between the corporeal and incorporeal but it seems still too corporeal
of a concept right I mean it's still a thing it's a material thing out there in the world
that's not what sense is right I mean it's he explicitly says that sense is incorporeal right
because it's an event doesn't belong first time he brings up the mist right, um, uh, metaphor he does
exactly that he's like and even this is all that's right corporeal right right he says it yeah
but it's a problem and it's the problem that all of these thinkers in this lineage that which is
irreducible to bodies but nonetheless only actualized through bodies like they're you know that's what
you're after so it's always a question of how do you I mean how do you you know Diane and I've had
this conversation for years of like how do you not talk about it because she is really often concerned
with talking about it alterity is her version of this right but how do you talk about it I'm like
it's not so much about talking about it's about rendering right it's about provoking or producing
and that's a different task it sets you a different task and I think that that different task means
unlike Nate's inclination which is you use bodies and then you show how that use of bodies fails
right to to kind of capture the thing that you're wanting if you don't think representationally
it's not a problem to use bodies right like it's because all you're what you're doing is not you're
not ever going to say well this is or you don't have to say well that's not really right because
it's not a question of being right you know but it's that's a hard thing to kind of get your head
around and to buy from a writer and certainly when he's writing this you know 40 years ago 50 years
Ago so it's hard to allow yourself to do too because you feel like you're
somehow cheating that you know you haven't done the labor of showing the indistinction between
them at first that's right no you're right and that is literally quite impossible and that's
always the challenge so for instance I think of my I think of the passage that you read uh a little bit
ago and the the idea of the sort of search for the whatever the imaginary thing was right like
right like that in some ways so I remember when I wrote the Sophist chapter of my invention book
because that's the claim of the of that chapter like that's the claim and yet I remember I was like
that's such a fucking banal claim right like the search is everything you know the sort of what you
find isn't and I was like it's really hard to make that claim do interesting work because it is
such a banal it's the process not the product it's the search not the desk not the goal you know and
it's it's very very difficult to make that claim do interesting work you know just because of its
banality you know well because the um I mean the the topoy of the search it's the search not the
the destination or the journey not the destination tends to like immediate like the gravitational force is on
like the personal emotional experience of the thing right which is very different from the point that
that's right so what another thing that kind of struck me so if we're if we're starting back on the
language chapter um you do have a sort of early version of he's going to invent different words for
things right he's not going to call representation representation um even though that's clearly what
he's talking about he's not going to call expression expression because he's saving the word expression
he's saving his expression is actually a more interesting concept than manifestation to him
right so he's sort of preserving it for that I mean I don't know if he's doing that intentionally or
anything I when did he the Spinoza book was prior to this right so he would have already liked the
he likes the term expression from Spinoza right so um so so you already have that but I was also interested
because unlike I think later Deleuze he's really interested in what I would say what I would call like
working through logic as opposed to just saying like I'm not I'm not playing that game and and that's the
Lewis Carroll hook I think is like because Carroll you know is was a logician right like he's really
he is trying to kind of he's like here are the normal ways of understanding right here are the
three normal ways and even what he does with signification there's a it's a tweak on what the
term signification would have usually how it usually would have worked uh at that time so but he's working
within the sort of domain of what I would call more analytic based thinking right like more logic based
thinking and and trying to inject sense into it right or or add it or what you know smear it over
the top or whatever else but that's a that's a different sort of um dispositional orientation than
than certainly you see with the Guattari uh by the time Guattari gets involved with the the writing so
which is interesting I mean because Lewis is a you know a British you know logician and I mean you
know in the same of a similar vein or at least in a similar um uh uh environment as say like J.L.
Austin it'd be it's interesting to read um Deleuze's relationship and orientation to Carroll next to
Derrida's um uh interjection and relationship to to Austin to Austin and and Derrida you know is he
there is something a little bit more patronizing about the way that Derrida takes uh Austin there's
like even what even when he's commending him it's sort of like you're you're a really good boy
J.L. for trying to work through this and what I love about you the most is how you just never
daunted when you run into a wall right um whereas Deleuze seems to be taking uh Lewis Carroll and his
work as an object of fascination to to think within now I mean it's probably because Lewis Carroll is
far more interesting than J.L. Austin um maybe that just has something to do with it but but that's it
you know I mean that's an interesting spin on it because I think the alternative the other way of
thinking that to me that that flips that the the valence on that is that Deleuze is just violent
with he'll just take things from people and he just doesn't give a shit about like Derrida is much more
careful uh in terms of the the the body of work the you know um whereas Deleuze is just like I'll take
this thing this thing is fascinating this guy's an absolute genius and he just ignores the things that
aren't uh interesting to him which is great I mean that's just a style of reading I there's really
but it's certainly that's why people say all the time I think like you know Deleuze's reading of X
doesn't sound anything like X it just sounds like Deleuze because Deleuze really cherry picks in ways
that Derrida is extremely careful not to cherry pick, you know, but there's also an incredible level of
precision. I mean, when I spent time with Deleuze's Kant book and then, you know, I was reading the third
critique next to it and, you know, I mean, it got to the point where I couldn't read Kant without
Deleuze prefiguring Kant, and so, like, he might work against the tradition, but I don't always think that
that's working against the text because no, oh yeah, I mean, that's sort of the point is he's not, he's not
making it up, it's, it's quote unquote there, but you know, he also will, he's very, he's a very selective
reader in that way, uh, whereas Derrida's always concerned to connect that even if it's a random
footnote or whatever, he wants to connect that to the logic of the work, right, or the logic of the
oeuvre or something like that, whereas Deleuze is just like no no no I'm just going to select
this particular thing and say it's the coolest thing ever and this is what Lewis Carroll discovered
and it's like, it reminds me of the Stoics and that's it, right? Yeah, yeah, I think this like speaks
back to to his method a little bit, you know. I think what I really appreciate about something
about someone like Deleuze or even Bart like this was really reminding me of Bart in some ways
is that these thinkers are very very comfortable living in banality and living in doxa
and even as they do that recognizing that in order to approach something like sex sex sex sense
something like wow clearly I woke up at five in the morning the quarantine days to approach something
like sense which is extraordinary right, in order to be able to get to the extraordinary you have to
pull in something like Lewis Carroll because we are all living in doxa and banality and you you
can't you you have to work with that if you're going to try to get to all of these paradoxes that come
all of the time in this work you know I mean there's and and every time there's another paradox
in some ways we're not even asked to like look at it as a paradox we're asked to kind of just
like again keep it moving keep it moving I don't know. Well, the flip side of that is is also like
what Lewis Carroll seems to do really well is show how fucking crazy banality is. Yeah, that's right.
That's right, yeah, I don't know if you all read the what the tortoise said to Achilles bit it's only
like two two and a half pages but it's just basically like you know the sequel to to Zeno's
paradox and it's I mean it's what Deleuze is doing here on page 16 I mean it's like it's indissociable
from from Carroll where it's like look if you have you know we think about the relationship between
premises and conclusions and if the premises hold and the therefore properly connects them to
the the conclusion then you know that then you have your the logical force of the piece, right? And
we just accept that it's like well look that's another proposition that's another proposition
right and you're never going to be able to add infinitum like you're always exactly adding
that you always have to have another proposition to justify why the logical progression is a logical
progression exactly which which then like I mean it takes all of the force away from logic writ large
so even our most basic basic I mean like think about what happens to argumentation if logic is
effectively like made impotent, right? It just it has no it's the the legitimacy it has force but the
legitimacy of its force is completely cut out right and that's on the one side of that's like that's on
the signification side of things but I think on the denotative side this is where denotation gets way
more interesting because it becomes much more so a creative act where it's like look here's here's the
that the violent act of the noun whereas it is going to impose states of affairs or it's going to impose
boundaries on becoming which are going to then like spur those becoming in different directions it's going
to act on them, right? And it's also going to bring its own metric, its own criteria for um thinking about
them in terms of their their truth or falsity and like look as long as long as you stop thinking uh
caring about correspondence here which would yes you know the success failure thing would would go out
along with it's like all right what is we're now we're now we're thinking about elocutionary force
across a few different fields like what is the elocutionary force of the denotative sentence and
what is the elocutionary force of of um of the logical series of propositions
sans any kind of justification sans any kind of naturally grounded like necessarily like an
unbreakable necessity that links them together right and and the movement where he is this this also
reminded me of his of his later work where he's talking about you know the perpetual um uh process
of form both being like form must always be conditioned by you know what you might call the
Molecular side of the plane of imminence, but then it is always then acting as a condition for something
else to arise, so the simultaneity of uh form always being conditioned and or in the process of being
conditioned and in the process of conditioning, to me, was, you know, I mean, to me, that's, that's really at
the center of this, this whole book, and he's sort of that dynamic to me, which again I think it's rendered
as the plane of imminence in Like a Thousand Plateaus is really at the center of every, all, all four of
these series that we've read so far, and I'm going to guess a whole lot more of them, and that that
flattening of the ontological plane, like you're saying, that's totally key for like making the
paradox more interesting, and I guess in some ways, like the constitutive paradox, like right, like the
the circle, the Hegelian or even maybe the Saussurian circle, right, that I mean that creates a pretty
complex paradox that is in some ways irresolvable, but what Deleuze is doing by flattening that is
saying like that even that paradox, which is kind of unwieldy in itself, even that doesn't go far enough,
you need to have, you need to be basically be like teetering on this line between consistency and
consistency rather than following this like vicious circle, you know, you like can you just do a little
bit of explication on on that particular paradox that you're thinking of? So, serious paradox.
Yeah, I mean, well, I mean, I was thinking more of Hegel's paradox where, um, where it's just the, the
circularity of the I of subjectivity where it's it's it's it's only basically referencing itself.
Even when you think you're referencing the world or an object or a referent, it just comes back to
sort of in placing the I, so there's no way to actually get out of that system, and it's he, I mean
he, he articulates it pretty clearly, um, when he talks about I think it's the signification section
in a serious situation or maybe yeah I think I think it's manifestation, yeah, yeah, yeah, um, where
the I is the basis of every proposition, right, and there's so many tradition there's like so many
traditions that are kind of co-mingling in this third series and especially in that manifestation
and signification section, like you got you got Descartes, you got Hegel, you have it sounds like
Saussure at points, you know, all kind of all kind of operating under a similar logic for Deleuze, you
know, that that's interesting because I hadn't made the connection with, because you as you're saying
it Nate, like I'm instantly going to that part that's the the the very beginning of the Phenomenology
itself, not the preface, and but the actual but remember those first few pages where he goes the I the
I object connection from sense certainty to the next to the next step whatever that was
understanding, I think, or whatever, um, but that is that there's a way in which this is directly
responding to that whether it's explicit or not I mean uh that it is like that notion of manifestation
is taken right out of that Hegelian thinking which is it is always an I that is the basis of even the
claims to know something about the world, right, or you know, like that there's an object, there's like
well that's a there's always an I that grounds that Hegel showed us that, you know, and he did
right, right, so right, yeah, that's good, that's a good connection. I see the Saussure connection that you
see here too between language and and speech parl, um, uh, yeah, and the deferral of meaning.
Yeah, you live in a Canadian-speaking country for fuck's sake.
I need to get the linguistic version of uh Duolingo, so you need to get your Duolingo action.
I think it's like this the third paragraph on page I mean like the first full paragraph on page 13, like
right when he starts talking about yeah manifestation, a second relation of the proposition proposition is
called manifestation; it concerns the relation of the proposition to the person who speaks and expresses
himself. Manifestation therefore is presented as a statement of desires and beliefs, which correspond to
what's the intention of desires and beliefs are causal inferences not associations? Desire is the internal
causality of an image with respect to the existence of the object or the corresponding state of affairs,
which I thought brought us back to denotation quarter correlatively belief is the anticipation of this
object or state of affairs insofar as its existence must be produced by an external causality.
How does that resonate with you all? Well he also he undoes that in the next two sentences right where
he says for you know Hume is the one who taught us that causality is not causality like causality is
just a form of association, um, so that what seemed like not associative simply but causal is in fact that's
where I mean when he wants to claim that obviously uh that manifestation is it is um
it manifestation makes denotation possible, right? It's a condition for denotation, so belief is the
Anticipation of this object or state of affairs, this is must be produced by an external causality. Yeah.
I mean, to to me, I mean, that's sort of recognition would be the Hegelian, right, for that, yeah? I mean, and
then here it's like the I, the Hegelian I, which is what is basically being articulated here, it's pretty
empty. I mean, it's it's it's not signifying any substantial content, but it seems like Deleuze is
saying it's not empty enough. Like later, not here, but he's he's basically just summarizing it here, but
when he goes to the the the not the deeper paradox but the the paradox that he's really after, it's like
the I is even more vacuous than the Hegelian I, like it's it's simply a result of of like other
significations. Well, it's not even it's not even a form of movement, which it is for Hegel, right? It is a
form of dialectical progression. It's like it's not even that at the level of sense. Yeah, you know, it's it
doesn't it's like an arbitrary effect. It's an arbitrary effect, for Deleuze, for Hegel it's an
it's an essential necessity. Yeah, you know, yeah, right? But that's why when we were redoing the
Hegel thing I was like this just all feels so psychological to me. Like the whole thing felt so
psychological, you know, psychoanalytical. I mean, very Lacanian. It just they neatly, you know, fold into each
other. Yeah, for sure. I mean, looking back historically now that we know sort of Lacan, Zizek, it's like, oh, well
obviously it was psychoanalytic. I don't know if it was intuitive, you know, a century ago, but probably not.
Yeah, I'm just, I'm still though curious. I mean, I I understand that manifestation becomes the
condition of possibility for denotation and when he introduces signification he's sort of like I mean
the thing that he really wants to undermine is that we're going to find some kind of grounding or
foundation for like like look signification, the sort of like the logical relationships between
language is going to be the condition of possibility for both manifestation and therefore denotation.
None of this works that it you know, and this is how you have to turn it into a Mobius strip that
sentences the sort of mist that holds it all together whatever. Um, but I'm I'm just the the language of
desire and belief here is interesting to me and I I just I don't know if you do you think that that
kind of gets um jettisoned in uh because I mean it comes up, you know, a lot of places and obviously
oh I see desire, I get your question now. Yeah, it's interesting. So so if I does this does this make
sense because I'm reading this as him summarizing the usual ways of treating language? Yeah, and
manifest and manifestation as you know, and so he's some when he's saying that he's summarizing desires
and beliefs are causal inferences not associations people say, right? Like people say that desires and
beliefs or scholars have thought desires and belief are caught are are causal, hence giving a kind of
ground, right, for for what we would call denotation and and then to me then the next move is like but by
the way that causality while still real is just an is just an associative sense-based move, right? So I
take him to not be in other words he's not asserting that desires and and beliefs are causal, he's
summarizing others. That's my take on it. Um, I had some unless we do something with we do something with
desire which he obviously will do later but like something with desire where desire is not subjective at
all, right? Yeah, which is why I mean that's what I want to I mean that's the only reason I really asked
the question is yeah the chance to think through the question of desire and belief and they're more
interesting. Gotcha, um, iterations, right? I had similar questions I think I'll come up in later series. Yeah.
No, I don't think we're a desiring machine yet here, right? This is this would be more of a humanist desire
that he's that he's kind of outlining. Yeah, but I had similar issues with a couple sections because
I'm like is he simply summarizing a like sort of theoretical apparatus that he's then going to
complicate or is this Deleuze asserting his own proposition? I felt like there was some tension
there in a couple paragraphs, like because a lot of it a lot of this seems structuralist like
Saussurean or whatever, but I'm like that can't be Deleuze, right? I mean it's like he's he's gonna
introduce some kind of twist uh into my take is that at each point whether it's the denotation what he
does with the indexicals there uh the the manifestation which we've just talked about what he does with uh
the sort of flipping causality and showing causalities associated he's doing both, right? Like in that sense
of saying here's the usual way of understanding language and even on those terms it's way weirder than
you normally think of it being, right? So signification is for me one where it's much clearer because his
sense of signification there is really different than Saussure, you know? I mean it's about the sort of
logical connectivity of propositions is what signification means and not necessarily logical but still. Um.
And so therefore like that so he's like here's a summary of the thing but but the thing itself is
actually weirder than you normally would think that the you know your normal understanding of, say,
manifestation, which is that when I speak it's an expression of of self he's like, you know, you would
normally put it under you'd lump that that you would uh uh categorize that under desire or belief manifests
itself in my speaking, and desire and belief in that case are actually uh associative sense-based
uh um moves and so yes, fine, it's desire and belief but desire and belief weren't aren't mine and they're
not the usual you know association connection, causal connection that you make now all these
fucking words I can't say them anymore well I mean that's that was exactly my experience and hence
that question early on because you know I especially the first time I'm reading it through it does feel
like he's just summarizing something I'm like wait a second this is a really pretty you know idiosyncratic
way of summarizing this thing and it's transforming as as as I read it so you know even like
manifestation it's like all right you know the eye or the statement is manifested from the subjective
position of the eye but you get even just a little bit into that and then suddenly you're realizing that
the eye itself is just the side effect of that's right other kind of movement which doesn't change
the fact that the eye in this in this sort of like um like in the spoken register is still doing work
right that's right it's just no it's just not an absolute origin point it is you know as to go back to
that that section that I read earlier you know it is the form that is being conditioned at the same time
that it is conditioning conditioning yeah right yeah and I think I think he knows I think why desire
seems to be kind of like a flashpoint here and kind of throughout is because I think he he knows or senses
that um you know we have a lot of we have a lot riding on wanting to believe that some kind of unity
comes out of you know the eye forming amongst others right um and that we want to believe in that in
that unity but but also believe in our subjectivity really believe in the subjectivity at that moment
too um and so I you know the fact that you know that he's that he's connecting desire and belief makes a
lot of sense to me because the stuff that he's trying to show are just you know the given and the kind of
like here's what they say um it's still stuff that makes us feel secure because of course it does
right right well I think about where he's talking about the the danger of losing your name and
the disorientation of Alice losing her name right that is I mean that's a scary place to be
yes but I think interestingly enough you can hold on to both of those things so so the question of is
is he summarizing or intervening you know you know you can do both right so you can say like a
sentence like this desire is the internal causality of an image with respect to the existence of the
object or the corresponding state of affairs that's on the one hand a summary of the usual way of
understanding things which is that like hey I say whatever and that's a manifestation of
my desire you know and it's like yeah that's that's true at the same time desire is is or the basis of
causality is associational or sense right in that regard and so therefore that thing I mean in other
words you still have desire you still have everything that you have it just doesn't function exactly the
same kind of linear uh or grounded grounded way so you can have them both it can be both a summary of
other people's things and an intervention in that I mean I don't you know I mean I yeah it just seems
like it doesn't have you don't have to pick yeah you're right but the also I mean like you're saying
Caddy again the the desire for unity that seems to be like the thing that Deleuze just across this
whole oeuvre is kind of battling against right just doesn't the implicit desire for unity like
the libidinal almost desire for unity especially here invoked by the cogito like when he when he
displaces the the dualism between true and false to is it like belief and non-belief or it's like the
cogito is just simply believing in the self it's not it's not a self-present unity it's the desire for
that self-present unity and it's a kind of stubborn desire for that that Deleuze obviously is not on board
with in any like naive sense you know what I mean although I don't think I mean this is where I mean
this goes back to our constant conversation Nate is that I just don't think in some ways for him it's
not like there isn't desire for a totality like that's consciousness's misunderstanding of desire
right is that there isn't in fact what you see actually happening is dispersion and so there is
this whole notion of that the eye wants to kind of you know unify itself is like that's not what
people actually like humans that's not what they actually do that's how they understand poorly what
They do, but it's not like all they're doing is trying to connect to a whole assortment of things
and produce sense and provoke sense, so how did you how would you ever get the understanding
like Hegel that you're trying to totalize and complete yourself because that's just not how humans
or anything else really operates, you know? Right, because I kind of more it like um, you know, in in
Difference and Repetition the the cogito and Descartes are like he's really sort of taking that taking
Descartes apart, but here he seems to have a much more immanent relationship to Descartes where like
he's talking about like look the forget about the the groundedness of the cogito, start thinking about
its function of the positing of the eye or the positing of of self-certainty and what is the function of that
positing? So, on 15, um, uh, this is shortly after he makes the speech language distinction, and and I think
he's still talking about he's coming back to manifestation, so that first full paragraph the
question of whether signification is in turn primary relation to manifestation and denotation requires
a complex response, for if manifestation itself is primary in relation to denotation it is if it is
the foundation it is so only from a very specific point of view and there's where like he's he's constantly
doing the summary thing and the intervention thing, I think, you know, far from like not having to choose
between the two you can't because the summary is also the intervention. Yes, all right, so yeah, there
i'm undoing foundations by showing that there are foundations but only from certain perspectives and
only in certain articulations, um, so to borrow a classic distinction we say that it is from the
standpoint of speech be it rather uh be a speech that is silent uh in order uh in the order of speech it is
the eye which begins and begins absolutely in this order therefore the eye is primary not only in
relation to all possible denotations which are founded upon it but also in relation to the
significations which it envelops but precisely from this standpoint conceptual significations are
neither valid nor deployed for themselves they are only implied though not expressed by the eye
presenting itself as having signification which is immediately understood and identical to its
own manifestation. This is why Descartes could contrast the definitions of man as rational animal with
his determinations as cogito, for the former demands an explicit development of the signified concepts
what is an animal what is rational whereas the latter is supposed to be understood as soon as it is said
Right, yeah, I mean that's kind of what I meant like the coach it's like so in the face of radical
contingency in the face of becoming like in in Deleuze's terms one way of negotiating that would
be asserting the totality of the eye which is kind of what the cogetto does which is what
Descartes aims to do but what Deleuze is saying is that's merely one way of dealing with that and it's
not it's not definitely not the best way it's not the way he's interested in so it's like I don't know
I mean I think Descartes is in some ways like unable to to see that his his central proposition rests on
a flawed presupposition, right? I mean it's like the the coach doesn't need um to defend its central
premise which it doesn't know that either, sorry that was like a convoluted uh statement
Well, it's to say that Descartes asserted asserts the cogito without recognizing the perspective from
which the cogito emerges and what the force of the cogito is that that's the move that I like and
and many other like Derridas certainly does this and it's as a sort of conceptual move I love it
rather than arguing against your target show that your target is an example of the this other kind of
thing, right? So if if we saying could the cogito is the target here he's not saying the cogito is wrong
and fuck this I think stuff he's not trying he's not critiquing it externally in any other you know
in any as usual that that's the immanent critique move is like well actually that cogito is right on
as an expression of a certain uh orientation, right? you know, it's diagnostic but by the way it's that
orientation which is the really messy weird thing that can enable it to go in different kinds of
directions, you know, right? I also love the locution this is a Deleuzianism that I i have mimicked at
times in my life the the this is why um and then to go on and pick some random thing that someone has
written and just take a sentence out of them like there's there's an earlier one of like this is why
Lewis Carroll abandons the the original title of Alice's Adventures Underground like moving to surfaces
and it's like I love that I mean I love that move because you're like here's a random fact, yeah a
thing associated with this you know with the writing of this book that that he's linking into and he's
saying here's an explanation for why that happened and again not that Lewis Lewis Carroll didn't ever
Have to think that didn't ever have to consciously in any way be aware of it or even kind of unconsciously
Like no no no that's just how desire works man it it just produces all of these like that move with
Descartes this is why Descartes has to explain the rational animal part but doesn't have to explain
the code which it's like that's that's why it's just such a um to me it's an incredibly pithy uh
conceptual move you know we even does it um reflectively as well sometimes like this is
why we will not ask the question right blah blah blah blah which he does like within pages of that
example i've just explained this too you know idiosyncratic thing that that you would never
have thought of and probably didn't know but i read a bunch of stuff about Lewis Carroll and this
struck out at me and is like oh this makes sense in this conjunction
i mean it makes perfect sense when you're thinking it makes perfect sense right yeah
for me the virus thing that i wrote years ago that whatever like that's it's filled it's filled
with those kinds of moves of like this is why the virus like and i'm making biological claims there
which are ridiculous you know but at the same time it's like there's a logic to this right there
is a logic to the sense and there's connections among these things that in most cases you would just
say well you're just making an association it's like well but maybe associations are how things work
right you know yeah or i mean to go back to Hume like uh causalities and you know correct
associations are or only associations that have accrued a certain amount of doxic weight to them
right i mean they're inferences they're they're associations that ground i mean what's his he even
quotes from Hume in that passage there wherever the hell we were on causality stuff of like
oh inference so Hume said in the association of cause and effect it is inference according to the
relation which precedes the relation itself right causality is just a residual habit i mean that's
what Hume says right to call this i mean you don't see things cause other things you see one thing
happen and another thing happens and you infer a causality right and that inference precedes so you
you know like causality is an inference of just association i mean you know the fact that the fact
that we have to answer or that you have to answer i haven't had to answer this yet but the fact that
you've had to answer to oh this is just association or associational thinking you know suggests that
everyone in the thinking scholarly world is subsumed in that kind of in the in what Deleuze would
call it it's kind of ridiculous where we think that in order for signification to make sense
signification has to own sense or has to be a control of sense what has to be good good sense
good sense right yeah and and sense it's just not gonna it's not going to behave that way since
there's gonna there's gonna be a remainder or an excess that um you just can't handle with
significant the signification is just you know so it makes well it's interesting to me to to think like
what drives the worry of that you know mere associationism or you know the way it gets also
this is also the fear of relativism right that if anything goes because it undermines what i do by
finding the correct legitimate things and if anybody can connect anything to anything that
you know undermines the value of why i do and there's no way of parsing out you know the good and bad
versions of this and to me the irony is that like the the the labor of trotting out the correct i.e.
the most weighted and well-trodden associational networks is mere labor and the the the ear and the
attunement and the and the creativity that's required for parsing out the idiosyncrasy and the singularity
of what is an infinite uh set of available associations to make frankly requires a whole lot more to it you
have to be way way better you have to be far more nuanced and attuned to you know to chart out all these
specific connections that need to be like all right well i i made sure that all my t's are crossed and
my eyes are dotted and i did it in in the right way and effectively you know just you know scraped
off another millimeter of this of the of the dirt and this sort of rut that we're creating this is the
i i mean i this is the response i got to that virus piece uh and and i've gotten several other times which
is effectively they don't say this but this is effectively it's like it's too paratactic where's
the hypotaxis and i'm like but the whole point is that hypotaxis is a development of parataxis right
like that it's just uh hypotaxis just parataxis that have been repeated a lot right have become
a picture like you put things next to one another and we suddenly start calling them causal or we
suddenly start calling it an argument like you make a series of points and then you know we make it
An argument, but it's like no no it's got to have hypotaxis otherwise why would a reader care and
i was like, well, i, that question i don't fucking know about because i don't know what the fuck people
care about. Well, this brings us right back to Zeno's paradox thing, right? That, you know, i mean, when you
start thinking about space as being carved up in distinct points, then, like, how could there ever be
any movement with with anything? How could there be any hypotaxis without parataxis first? That
um, but but but think of the conventional understanding: parataxis is failed hypotaxis. It's the name
issue, right? That's the usual way. No, no, i just, you know, in other words, like, there's a totality towards
which you're pointing, and parataxis is the failure of that. It's it's hypotaxis gone, or i mean that's
a way of understanding, a way of understanding it from the perspective of the eye. Hypotaxis is crazy
right? Or sorry, parataxis. Parataxis is is crazy because it's just making random associations and
for instance, the argument would be what parataxis does is it replaces the locus in the object which
is where it should be with a locus in the subject, which is that's the errancy, which is just like
that's John's associational pong, right? i mean that's the way of understanding parataxis is the unity of
that dispersion is found in me. In other words, things that i thought, things that i saw, things and so it's
it's not that it's lacking in unity, it's just lacking in, right, the the appropriate kind of unity. Yeah, it
does upset the whole telos obviously, like, and i like he's also very insistent that there's no
there's no utilitarian justification for sense. He says that explicitly somewhere, like it's not a utility
um, i mean it might become a utility, and certainly it is, like our senses allow us to negotiate the world
but that's not the telos of our subjectivity or whatever, that's just a result of the connectivity of
of sensuality or of senses, right? It's not that we're it's not that we're it's not that our bodies are like
garnering our senses in order to master or appropriate the world, it's that we're able to
appropriate our environment because connections are made, you know what i mean? It's like it's a reversal
of the Hegelian, yeah that's right, logic in some way, yeah yeah i like that. Well i'm gonna try to say
this differently because i want to think through it, um, that, and i'll take us back to the very first
series of the mad becomings and you know the question of how becoming always eludes the present because
it's not in a state of being, it's always in the state of of responding to otherness, right, or um
you know, it's always in the process of growing smaller and larger at at the same time, um
and like to think about association if we tend to think along a logic of resemblance, right? Here is
here's a thing and as and i associate it with this thing because of some kind of determinant um uh
resemblance between between the two things and then we sort of say all right, well these are the
these are the resemblances that matter and these are the ones that don't matter, like for example warm
bloodedness is a is a an association that matters but color is not hair color yeah that that that matters
right, um, and you know obviously this this is going to position the relata before the relation that the
relation is is produced out of the relata uh by if we're going to rethink association as prior then we have
to think about association not i mean like any association what you did in the virus piece what
what Deleuze is doing here like any association can never be an association of resemblance that
now a subject comes in and and notes and and markedly it is always the becoming in response to
the thing that it associates with and those bonds either get more and more
distinct or more and more muddled and and confused like there's only ever a growing into
and out of these what we sometimes might call disparate terms and other times we might call
unified, you know, substances, you know, depending whenever wherever we're at the scale but like
um, yeah, that association is always becoming associated or to think about uh that's the wasp orchid
um, metaphor is that it's always like it's always the wasp and the orchid becoming a relationship to each
other which has nothing to do with and that's an association uh or in an like in an alliance that has
nothing to do with a resemblance or a similarity between the wasp and the orchid which then literally
means that everything can be associated with anything else the rhizome but then it takes the work of
actually doing that, right? That that's the sense in which uh, you know, multiplicity is a constructivism
it has to be made. It's not just it's not an ontological claim to that's the case it's like
you got to make the links, right? Now it doesn't have to be humans it can be the earth, right? Like
i mean but whatever so you just have so association in this in this sense is a word for both difference
and becoming like if you could if you could put those those two concepts together, which I mean obviously
he does in difference in repetition, you know, but um but yeah what's wild to me is that that is so
antithetical to the way that we think about the word association and what it does and yet it makes
so much sense I mean it's literally just to associate, right? I mean like just from the latin
like allies. Yeah, so but by the way that I think is what's distinctive and we'll have we'll talk about
this later when we talk about the Hegelian thing but that's what's distinctive I think about what we're
doing here in this context and to think of a model of learning because that's how we're operating
right like we're not operating hypotactically there's no I mean none of us are experts here none of us
are philosophers right like we are making associations like Katie said about her reading
like we're making associations and we're doing it collectively among each other and that that's a
mode of learning that at least to my mind is fairly it's certainly not institutionalized right like
you never I mean when does the circumstance we say get some smart people together and talk about
something and that's going to be your model for education right I have this I I don't know if you
had this experience Nate because I'm going to guess you just used a different body of text to teach by
when I first started teaching first year composition and Christie Friend was the director of FYE and she
had us use the David Bartholomew Petroski Ways of Reading thing and you know there's just like a
it's like a big anthology of you know like really difficult texts in there and you're supposed to teach
writing by having students read these really difficult texts and there was such an anxiety
on the part of so many um instructors of not like having the proper training to teach
Foucault right or and you know Christie tried to say over and over again you're not that's not
your job like that's you know you're you're using this text as a mechanism by which to teach
writing by working through the piece by writing about it but your goal was to not teach the the um
the content of Foucault they're not supposed to come out as little mini Foucault scholars on on the other
end and I don't know if I had this sort of orientation already or if that experience sort of helped provoke
that orientation in me but I've never then had a problem um with selecting text for a class where
I'm worried about selecting the right text because it's like all right I I I will piece through a
handful of things I'll kind of see you know can I see roughly a line in there whatever line I see in
there initially it's going to be made differently for this class and the next time I teach even if I teach
the exact same text the line will get made differently in fact the worst thing I can do
is pre-inscribe what that line is going to be and try to force the others and try to force my students
to see it and because it's just sort of it is forcing the singularity that allowed the one the first
line to come out onto another composition which it's that could be that could be deadly to that body
right yeah it's such a controlling sort of just standard authoritarian mode of teaching to do that
and I've always but it's all but it's all teaching like that's right teaching is as an entity is to
people into a hypotactical movement right it's all in other words what we're what we're doing now
and what I'm thinking about you know in terms of you know the various movements in the associational
logic most people wouldn't say we're learning yeah we're just talking about stuff what's the body
of knowledge that we are acquiring right we're not producing a body of knowledge we're not having
I mean maybe we are but like pretend that we're not actually doing it but like we're not developing
a better understanding of blues or Hegel and if we're not doing that then we're not
fucking learning yeah right well I'm learning oh no no I agree no no I just no I mean like I actually
I actually think that right here right now we are developing a Delusian pedagogy because like I said the last
time the next time I teach digital rhetoric I am teaching The Logic of Sense and I am teaching
stuff from Alice in Wonderland and I don't know to what ends and I don't fucking care because
because because really what Deluze wants us to one of the the big things he wants us to understand is
that sense is discovery and that sense is not just in order for sense to really kind of to work
I don't want to say optimally but you know what I mean like to really stretch to really stretch along
that flat you know circle it has to meet new machinery and that new machinery might be something
like Foucault right and it's just gonna it's gonna stretch it it's gonna um elongate the the
boundary even more um it doesn't have to it doesn't have to you know march along right this is what I
Mean for me, like picking the things to read has always been the easiest thing ever. It's like it
doesn't fucking matter. I'll just put in the other. The other one that this makes me think of is and this
you hear this a lot is the the notion of the imposter syndrome thing, which I've never felt like I've
just never felt that way, but it's premised on a notion that you're assuming a position of expertise
and if you don't think that you're assuming a position of expertise, why would you ever have
imposter syndrome? It's like I'm not an imposter because I'm not an expert or wanting to be or
think of myself as being or, you know, it's like no no, I'm just a person who thinks about stuff
in relation to other things and makes connections and so how could I be an imposter? That's all I do.
I think the way I think the way out of imposter syndrome or the way out of thinking about expertise
is really just to think, and this is how I always think about myself. It's like I'm an expert at
thinking in particular ways. I'm not necessarily an expert in like a scholar or, you know, like I'm
you're an expert in style. I'm an expert in style. Will you write the blurb for the back of my book?
We've brought up that some of the professional institutional realities, um, you know, in our
conversations in the past a bit is that the capacity to lose, I think you've said something to like this
jobs. Like when did you lose your sense of imposter syndrome? When you got tenure, right? Yeah, or
like and like that's when it got eradicated. You know, I know for me I lost a good chunk of it
when I got the job. I think I'll lose the rest of it when I get tenure, and and like for for example
Nate isn't in an institutional place to to that's right do that. Yeah, it's more precarious.
Job interview where you were going to have to posture yourself as the expert and you're going
to get poked and prodded to see if you really are the expert, which is going to be an art of
bullshit, right? It is, yeah, because that's that's like because the fact that you're good at what
you're that what you do actively means that you're bad at the things that they think you should be good
at. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, the the art of interviewing, it really is the art of bullshitting. I mean, Jesus
Christ, you're really lying about every facet of yourself to some extent, you know what I mean?
But and that's why I that's why I love the inner. I mean, to me, I've always the interviews are my
favorite parts being the object or, you know, being on the other side because it really is like let's
just sit around and throw some shit out and see see what happens, right? And like and that's why it's
like I want to hire this person that wants to play. That's when I've always been like and I there have
been people who've been very smart and very I mean that we've interviewed and I'm like they don't want
to play. Like they want to be experts and I don't want to hire them. Yeah, right, right, yeah, yeah. I was
going to say one ironic thing about the um association and whether or not we're we're learning and you
know in the in the traditional sense I think I don't think we are and then in a very different
sense I think that's all we're doing, um, but this has been such a different read for me coming out of
the Hegel sequence because like so many of our conversations now are bearing on my reading of
this text and this reading of this text is bearing on our conversations about Hegel and the irony is
that that has not yet happened when he mentions the word Hegel. It's happened in all these other
places but never when he actually talks about Hegel which isn't all that often.
I have one final thought on the uh the sort of authoritative teaching model versus the kind of
uh playful one, um, I've always and I don't I mean I don't think this is necessarily the right way to
approach reading or writing but I've always just kind of uh select I've been selective with my
interpretations and I've always like sampled stuff that I knew that I could use so stuff that I don't
understand uh on a first or second read like it doesn't paralyze me or it doesn't typically paralyze
me and like I don't feel like I have to comprehend the whole text and that's what I try to tell my
students like find something that works if you're tackling a difficult text like Foucault or if I'm
giving you some Judith Butler like please don't try to comprehend the entire thing I mean that would
be unwieldy within the the time constraints that we have. Find something that works for you and respond
to that and I mean that's always kind of been my my approach. It's also hard I mean I I just I mean
this is another variable that has really nothing to do with our conversation but it's it weighs on me
all the time is I try to think back of who I was 18 to 21 years old. I was not in a fucking place where I
had any remote interest desire, you know, it's like so to me I mean that's why like the classes that I
teach now all i try to do is once a class meaning once you know once a class period i want you know
a chunk of students to go huh that's kind of interesting and if i accomplish that i had a great
teaching day that's it right like so in that sense it's just like all i'm actually trying to do is to
provoke a tiny spark of interest in thinking that's it right like that's all i'm not trying
to get them to know anything i'm not trying to get them to understand anything i'm just trying to get
them to like foster a kind of desire right like huh that's kind of cool like that feels good to be
you know to have my curiosity spark that's it you know it's at that age group you know and for me
it certainly wasn't until grad school i mean until like my mid to late 20s where i was even capable
you know of of learning in that more conventional so i had any interest in learning in that more
conventional sense at all you know yeah i totally agree i mean it was you know the the big
um take away from my undergraduate career was developing a style the capacity to think through
things and you know whatever content that i had was you know tertiary at best like i mean just sort of
like it just so happened to stick i had these little you know anecdotes or maxims or factoids sort of stuck
to me but you know the only thing i really took away from it which is the most important thing i
could have taken away from it was yeah it was it's a Isocrates is the figure for this right and i i mean
i i there's literally not a class that i've taught in the last 15 years at any level where i don't say
this of like Isocrates philosophy of education was we know you're going to forget the content that we're
talking about we as a teacher i know that like i know that in five years there's going to be no
lesson no content lesson from your college experience that you remember and that doesn't
mean that you're wasting your time doing this like that's the usual well why are we learning this if
we don't need to know it's like no what you're doing is you're provoking desire and you're canalizing
certain ways of being in the world that's what's that's what's happening and you know at some future
point maybe you'll hook into you know knowing and it's you know more conventional sense but like
i mean that to me it's Isocrates is a figure for that like the purpose of that you know pseudo
proto-liberal arts thing is we're teaching them so they have the capacity to learn that's what you
know we know you're not going to remember anything we're not going to learn now and we can't teach
you every possible thing that's going to happen to you in the future we just want you to be able
to learn from situations so but continuing education that's that's sort of like a continuing
education model that's all you should learn and then you like then go off and learn it's
so antithetical to the corporate style of what continuing education is now how do you know how
would you measure you come back and you pay us more money and we'll give you more content like
what are the what is the learning what is the learning outcome there right like we'll have an
understanding of you know you're like i just got a tweet from a student like a direct message who um
he just graduated he was just saying hi and and was like i you know both the classes i took with
you were my favorite i can't tell you what we talked about necessarily but i can i can tell
you that like they stuck with me and but that's a good student yeah no it is a good student you know
and it's just i think we're you know for me it just i don't know why i go to Cicero here because this is
not really Cicero but like i i think of teaching really as inventional because if invention really
is just thinking out loud and and the moment of exhale and the moment of like giving breath to like
just something weird and different like i that's that's teaching that's fostering that's fostering
dispositions as opposed to yes you know really structuring everything about content and memorization
that's the that's the pedagogy that's not to be hook for the style book is exactly that like
all we're doing is is provoking and cultivating dispositions that's it and that's all that's all
we can do that's not a that thing right no not at all and i i don't want to be or i don't want to
be overly cynical but even that you know into the learning outcomes that has been codified not
what we're talking about but in a vague way like the critical thinking skills like they've they've
imbued the learning outcomes with a dispositional sort of like you know what i mean we're we're
fostering a corporate disposition you know a way to critically think through different you know in
different contexts applied learning writing across the curriculum you know all that yeah but that's
great i don't have i don't have a problem with that the task and yeah the metacognitive
The metacognitive thing that kills you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But I don't have, I don't have a problem with
that. That's not necessarily, like, I don't have an aversion to the idea of, like, the, that, that corporate
America could be, it could actually be interested in facilitating this kind of, um, thinking outside of
the box, uh, you know, that's what, that's the term for it, right? Experimenting, um, experimental thinking
uh, because at very least I think, first of all, for whatever lip service is paid to it, that's not at
all what they're interested in doing. Like, I just don't think that that's actually, you know, right, but
also if they were, how much cooler would capitalism be? Right? Like, how much more, you know what I mean?
Like, okay, thinking outside of the box, how about this: we don't care about profits for a year
Right? Let's try. That's not the box they want to think out of. Exactly. Well, that's my, that's my
point. That's my point is that if they actually were doing that, right, I would have no problem with
this, but I don't think it's, it's like thinking outside of the box, but very much designed towards
a particular telos, you know, so
you know, so